the segment I want to talk about is kin
games be so bad that they're good I
think there are few obvious standouts
that we want to talk about but I thought
that was that game so a universal thing
which we want to show off was a good
segue into this the first one I want to
get into the one that one that I want to
bring the table is obviously deadly
premonition because sure clearly they
were going for it but would regard
though the movie detective cheesy
dialogue kind of like I'm when you want
to all of that and with you on all of
that or I see it incidentally bad is the
fact that like the animations are like a
mechanics aren't that great there's not
many go but they're not great right
begin with playing the game is not that
good watching it as fascinating as hell
did you play through the whole thing
no really have to be ready for it it is
storm prints on you that sadly
permanence is so good that it's good it
is yeah tough to get through not in the
same way obviously a movie you can watch
and it's awful and it's funny because
it's awful and you're like cool I'll be
done 90 minutes I can sit back like
maybe drink while I'm doing this I can
eat I could do any number of things with
your body what a holding a cup and
drinking or something I don't know I
went way too into that ages you're
involved in the shittiness so it's tough
it's tough that's why I wanted to the
segment was tan games be so bad that you
have to put a lot of time into a game
yeah to get anything out of it in a lot
of cases not all cases obviously but
like a movie you can watch for an hour
and then you're like ah I watched the
room and it was I was drunk and it was
so funny I think as humans we have the
right to subject ourselves to a waste of
time every once in a while whether it be
a 90-minute movie or however long Deadly
Premonition is but like you said kelly
games take a lot longer they involve
more agency you can't just
I forgot Matt Saunders game is but this
aya log is really bad it's I encourage
you to try it the director's cut I think
is the way to go I think it made a
little few of the bad parts not as bad
to get you through I mean look at this
oh man animations it looks like this
theater that's way too tall I don't know
what's going on I forgot that's a red
reference to Twin Peaks but yeah Deadly
Premonition because I've never seen Twin
Peaks
oh yeah it's a tough show to get through
it's very much a soap opera for like 75%
of the show is it so bad that it's good
in time yes okay good points it is I
think a lot of people do that about what
the second season yeah yeah a drag
wasn't like bringing up the whistle
gube and Bob Jones what is that what's
the whistle theme is that the like main
theme of the game
I can't we don't have volume on our TVs
yes they said yes okay sure saying Moses
says yes no as the game which it's not
who did that Deadly Premonition it was
swearing yes did that as well as what
else do you do oh he did D for our
dreams don't die right is that really a
bunch of stuff no no he's done more than
that no his dark dreams don't die the
what the economists for yeah I think so
oh did you just guess hey guess it was
somewhere in my subconscious but I guess
that's where it was found it how do you
any other examples you guys want talk
about they're a few Pete you probably
wanna talk about Yakuza yeah it's weird
though because it's okay it's like the
combat is bad movement feels bad the
graphics are bad but it's not a game
that's like good because it's bad mm-hmm
but it's a game that I will tolerate its
poor qualities because the stuff outside
of the shitty stuff is great
what about really good like is zero good
so you said Yakuza did you mean I know
the most recently okay yeah cuz yeah I
was we watch the stream that Pete and
Rob did though oh that one line from the
underwear guy what's his name
walking erection yeah
dong slider what if some other we have a
footage of yours of zero up right now
yeah what else is bad about this game
you gave an 8 right
and I I've it's been getting like
positive reception across the board if
you're really into the gravy biscuits is
right this game is awesome the problems
are obvious though I mean you can't deny
that this game is deficient in so many
ways but the rest of its great I don't
know how you could give it less than an
eighth with a character like walking
erection yeah someone had mentioned I
figured forgive me your name passed me
by and the twitch chat bring it back up
if you can the game informer our friends
over there they do replay yeah and the
Facebook like community group for replay
is called the over blood community group
and that's because like over blood was
the first time they did a super replay
which is when they played it through an
entire game where they died like right
at the beginning and over blood is one
of those things where it's really cheesy
there's a robot I forget its name but I
there's all these inside jokes with the
replay community because of over blood
and they call it like the super over
blood replay hopefully people in chat if
there any game informer fans bring that
up but over blood is definitely never
played it and I only watched a little
bit of it because I didn't have a time
to go through the whole thing with the
game of former crew but apparently it's
a seminal part in the replay cannon
I'm waiting footage here we got footage
of the skin it's yeah forgive me I think
we might have it but it's just polygamy
shitty graphics here we go this is the
beginning you have to find this vest
that keeps you warm so you don't die and
that's how I push blocks yeah and it
doesn't get the robots name but it
becomes this this idiotic robot that
just pops up at the worst times
is it turd but the beginning is the most
obtuse puzzle that just doesn't make
sense when you're trying to get out of
this frozen lab Daniel Guardian Reichert
from Giant Bomb talking right now that
I'm kind of talking over I don't know if
I'm talking over him or not honestly but
I encourage you to go watch that it was
like a few years ago like Dan Reicher
still at game formers before he went the
Giant Bomb but it's worth watching it's
funny someone mentions godhand here very
similar
I think it's Archangel L three three
seven one very similar to yok is n so
many ways absolutely it doesn't play
very well it doesn't look that good
Pennsylvania 64 is really similar
no no but it's the humor it's the sort
of just oddball nature of it all that
makes it palatable okay I saw somebody
mention I'm sorry I did not catch your
name
blinks that Xbox game did you ever play
that game the cat the time-traveling
cats okay so I don't think I ever
finished like I don't know if this game
is actually bad or if I just remember it
that way because I it's the ER it's an
original Xbox game but basically you
just like stop time and do stuff but
you're like an anthropomorphic cat and
that's the shittiest description I can
give my horse Prince Oh
oh my god I really wanted my horse
prints as well so yeah so a lot of
dating Sims are are super bad and my
horse Prince is a mobile game where you
date a boy like an anime boy who has a
horse body and it's very entertaining
and ridiculous but not a good game by
any means but it's one of those I
hesitate to say like something that you
play when you're drunk but um it's one
of those things where you're like you
can just giggle about it all night it
sounds like the next Netflix original my
horse Bojack horseman is the head of a
horse body Will Arnett in animation form
yes so this is he's a reverse Bojack
horseman what if they just splice them
then or just be a show about a horse or
a man yes that's not nearly oh here's
footage I see what you're saying now ooh
a good-looking horse man at that oh yeah
look at him he's spark there's nothing
normal about you why is she smiling when
she says this oh yeah can we talk about
the voice acting yes so there's just
smiling a lot of say there's more scary
than strange this is a terrifying
experience so sweet DIRECTV Wow
I don't know about you but that's the
kind of date I want is terrifying oh my
god yes we'll take reservations for
three one for his but does he ever blink
um she was she's blinked a few times
she's blinking he's I don't think he
blinks see the fact that he has horse
ears he's an imposter it's just a face
on a horse not a head a human head on
human hearts I also gravy biscuits on
twitch says thoughtful boyfriend I would
like to refute that hot of a boyfriend
is a fantastic dating sim is that the
pigeon one yes yes deconstruction yeah
of the dating sim genre and if you've
played every route like I did because I
don't have a life then you would know
that it's fantastic but it has bad
quality I mean Julian is spotty at times
the reliance on puns is pretty shitty
yeah yes but I wouldn't say that's a
like that's not why I play it that's
another question it's like what is so
bad it's a bit is it like with movies
that are so bad they're good it's like
oh this is they tried really hard to
make a good movie they did not make a
good they thought they succeeded how
funny like the room is like the
quintessential example of that whereas
with a game it's more like oh we're kind
of talking about stuff that's like
either goofy or that we like despite its
bad qualities so I guess it's a
different qualifier because that's
really the question of the segment is
like can games be so bad they're good I
think it's a very different kind than
with movies or shows back to the room
real quick Tommy we saw his Rhett conned
himself I saw him in Texas at a
screening of the movie and he was
basically like oh yeah I'm just very
much into dark comedy this is a comedy
like he's claiming that this is all
himself didn't people think he was that
Robert the plane hijacker from the 50s
who stole a bunch of money and
disappeared oh I know who you're talking
to people thought John Shaffer was gonna
be this guy as well Hanan madman don't
say whether or not he is I mean if you
haven't finished Mad Men you should oh
my god you turn bright red oh yeah so
you brought up at a point doubly
premonition is bad so bad it's good
because of its like cinematic or lack
thereof qualities right but it's
something like goat simulator is
actually bad because if it's mechanics
but it makes it fun I think that's a
better example of how a game can be bad
but good piece is all gang beats - yeah
yeah I don't want to do it I don't like
if made of me wait John Luke you have
the gif of Pete ready now well show goat
simulator first I mean that that
definitely is the difference between
like a so bad it's good movie in us
about it's good game is like
games have gameplay and mechanics like
that can be the main oh yeah yeah Eric
green again also said it you'd probably
have to expect it to have bad qualities
to be able enjoy it like if it was bad
out of nowhere you'd have a hot much
harder time every single person in the
chat is saying that madmen is really
good ever yet yeah okay tastemaker
extraordinary yeah I think this was
another good example of how a game could
be bad but it's good and I just because
they purposely made the mechanics not
that tight right so you're just so dad
almost maybe no I feel like they really
tried to make back I mean like I mean
that's polish Oh like surgeon simulator
yeah nice keep hearing games that we
didn't plan on at first and they're
struggling to find b-roll I think if
they can find surgeon simulator footage
before we in this segment that'd be
sweet people talking about Earth Defense
Force or at Defence Force
yeah especially as it went on it became
I don't know if the production crew
knows this but we're hearing all the
audio from the b-roll you're screening
thankless myth in YouTube methods not
overrated I don't believe you okay
anyway Nicholas Smith I'm gonna end this
segment so we can get on to a Nintendo
switch which a lot of people are asked
for and then we're gonna talk about neo
after that I'm gonna switch over to the
next segment we're things up anyway
let us know any other games that you
think are so bad
they're good what is this honey on our
studio right now
see I am bread is a good one too alright
I'm moving on let us know on Twitter
Mike my hardy kelipah laggy Peter Brown
hit us up with games you think are so
bad they're good
[Music]